[Music]
that's
[Music]
stupid
[Music]
so i think we left off um
and she's right outside lady dimitrisk
it's right outside
i have no bloody clue what to do next if
i'm honest with you so we're just gonna
have to
explore and try and
use our brains to to figure out what
what there is to do but that could be
easier said than done
sorry about that i needed to go full
screen there
what no jesus christ okay
[Laughter]
he's laughing at me because i just
shortened oh yeah nothing at the wall
okay so is she out there she's not
oh the the music doesn't sound great
it sounds like she's out here
oh yep there she is so we finally eat it
we've already met before what are you
talking about
actor like with strangers wouldn't be
funny if you just came in here
can you help me out naturally yeah
he said yes
no i need the eye
combinable oh what can i combine with
this oh i have a lock pick as well
is there anything that needs i've gotten
some new stuff all right let's look at
on that
how do i get my map up
here we go right oh yeah so we have
these like
angels or whatever they are and they
need masks
we've got two of the masks
what does red mean does red mean we
haven't found
everything there yet because i'm pretty
sure we've been to all these different
places
uh we can't get out to the carriage gate
can we pretty sure it's locked and
that's probably what a red barrier means
that it's a locked door
yes we've got to find the rest of the
angel masks
and we have we have some keys
actually that we picked up so
[ __ ] it let's just walk around see what
we can find
huh
is she actually going to leave us alone
though
so we have iron insignia key which i'm
i think we found most the doors for this
one but this is new
is it not
maybe we haven't found all the doors for
this one because i feel like if we did
we wouldn't need it anymore and it would
tell us
a flower and swords motif
hmm where could we use that
i'm not doing great on health paper
which isn't the best especially when
lady
freaking is right nearby
keep going
you cannot see me
okay just maybe don't run is it like mr
x
because i didn't run anywhere with mr x
because i did not want to chance
anything
slap on the other side [ __ ]
dick sacks
why do i have my knife out that's really
not going to help me in any situation
there's nothing in that room and i know
that
i feel like there's nothing around here
can i give you a different eye no i
think i've already tried that
okay i don't oh [ __ ] keep thinking the
middle one
is menu and it's not right
i swear in the last game as though it
was but whatever
there's a terrace that i haven't been to
ooh
by lady demotress chambers which is
probably
where i want to be going to
what's that
it's all crossed out
um
yep so like oh and over here oh yeah
how did we get there right there's
there's
stairs to the other side of this locked
door which is locked from the other side
so we have to we have to find a way here
because we have the
insignia key
i wonder how we've got to go back
towards
dimitra's chambers
good
lady d lady lady
d d lady
oh [ __ ] every bloody time
what's up by the kitchen probably
nothing i'm gonna guess nothing
right how do we get to her bed chambers
i think it was this one this way over
here down here
i mean good on me for basically clearing
the area for when i came back after my
long break i didn't know that was gonna
happen
but i'm glad that i did it
these are just warning shots yes exactly
i know what i'm doing
i play games good i am girl gamer
pro
zero deaths
whoa that's a giant bathtub
whoa this is a bathtub
oh sweet i don't know why i need that
but i got it
uh i feel like i really shouldn't be in
here
oh i missed i must have missed this
before
okay but there's also
i have a key and it's her key with like
flowers and crap on it so i thought
i could use it
in one of her rooms so we're gonna have
a little look-see
around
hmm it's got to be here somewhere surely
i want to go to the terrace too and
through out through the terrace door
so another door this way
can i jump over here
i can't go back no i can't go back
but there's a door there
fine i'll have to go
the long way unless i can go i don't
think i can go through the hall of
can advocacy you no
guessing there's something in her
chapstick
aha
why have i got this does ethan want to
like
feel pretty or something i mean i'm not
judging
but why have i got this
ready there's something to see nothing
to take apart here
nothing hidden in the lid okay
okay
oh no i don't feel good about this
i wish i could remember what the hell
did i go down here
to get back up to this terrace bit oh
crap
the music's going funky let's just [ __ ]
it let's just go down
this episode's really going to be just a
recap
just me trying to remember what the
bloody hell
i'm doing here
no there can't be anything down here
surely
i've already been down here why am i
doing this to myself
i don't like it i don't like it spookies
if she came down here it would be
horrific
luckily i don't think she is going to
be here
no i think i think i think we're good
i think it's just the audio of the place
is super spooky
we found it
oh it's a safe room
i mean i'm not gonna a blade so
can we get out anywhere else is it just
here and we just
is this it i thought there'd be
something of use in this room at least
fine i'll take it i'll take it
is that ready yet
yes that that is it that is all that
there is here
oh crap can i not jump again i want to
go over there
i'm ready not go anywhere through here
that's not fair game
fine
ah didn't notice this chair before
[Music]
running through the blood i'm running
through the blood
and the spooky music and i'm running
through the blood
running oh what where's the
running through the blood running
through the blood
and the spooky music and i'm burning
through the blood
it still puts me on edge even though i
know nothing is gonna happen down here
it's just such a spooky place to be
right let's get back up
because back in the castle with lady d
is so much better
i mean actually yeah it is
okay so nothing up here we've definitely
got everything here
i think pretty sure
[Music]
we've got to get up to the other side so
if there's a door on the other side
that'd be great is there a door here
i can't see it's really dark it's a dark
for you guys this is just dark for me
oh i've been here
have i
how the hell do i get to where i'm
trying to get to
maybe there was a locked door in here
that i couldn't open before
so this is the special piano room i
remember this
i actually saw the comments saying look
behind you something's in your room and
i saw i saw this portrait of this man
because of the green screen and it
freaked me out
it's been around here
been all around here
[Music]
what am i missing i've got to be missing
something if anyone
does know by the way feel free to tell
me oh
wait
there i was saying that we'd use this
key
i freaking unlocked it
spooky also
gunpowder missed that before the name
okay
so you finally came to see me
oh no i can't leave
okay i've got to get something oh what's
this
what's this what's this
so mean i know
why are you doing this because i love
you
[Music]
oh [ __ ] why why would you do this
you really want to kill me of course
why would i know i want to kill you
you're trying to kill me
it's still she acts like i'm just doing
it because like
i'm just bored or something
where are you don't you love me no
oh i didn't know i saw it i didn't say
that earlier i was joking though
literally a dream this is a dream
oh everyone else was so happy ready
unless they were like so shallow they
just didn't care about you know
oh you'd be a part of me forever yeah no
i don't want that thank you don't
want it
oh she's dying
that's three i've killed all the
physicals now
see ya bye
not so shabby for two weeks off
thank you
so what actually happened when i did
this because i just i just saw the light
change oh
of course i can't can't do it anymore
well time to hear everything
can i not break this one no this pot is
an almighty pot it has people on it
oh that's a nice pillow i've been
looking at pillows
no one cares
uh
i keep wanting to pick up those little
jewelry boxes because they look very
cute
i know i know there's another door i
just want to check
everywhere for absolutely everything
although i i think i can just
yeah i think if it's red it means that
you haven't picked up everything that
there is to find
if i do remember from the last resident
evils
i don't know where i'd be though
i'm done here
so now yes we're in the hall
oh there's something to lockpick back
there
should we go back to lock picket yeah
let's do that because i've got a lot of
paper now
so it's down here
[Music]
and here somewhere
is it in here yes
do i even have that i don't think i even
have that
do i nope
but once i do
oh oh it's another mask
mask of joy
looks extremely happy in that situation
i mean who wouldn't be
what is this
i want to say it's a kiln but
i don't i don't know
a hat that's the door to the hole
okay so once i open this
something's gonna happen no nothing okay
what's this this looks like a
scary door
whoa there she is
wow what's the mechanical room
[Music]
can i make anything oh damn it
do i have anything i have
nothing for health so i need i need chem
fluid
okay let's let's keep an eye out for can
fluid
hello
is this how tall she is really probably
oh
let the five bells of this chamber ring
out
cute the snapping turtle
can i open that chest
okay so that's one bell but there's five
are there some that i might need to um
something something to oh there's
another one okay so there's two
is there one up here or is that just one
big bell
do you reckon i don't know oh that's a
little bell
okay so let's start shooting
it's on fire oh they become on fire okay
damn it
oh so close
come on
e
i don't think that is a bell
you would have thought there would be a
bell on the chandelier though wouldn't
you
uh i said how many i've got now one two
three three there's well we haven't gone
up here yet
hmm
[ __ ] knew it but there's still one
more somewhere
is there a bell in the portrait
that would be cool if there was like a
bell in the portrait and then you shot
it and then the whole portrait went into
flames and then lady d was like
came in and got real angry
where could it be
oh my gosh it's here
sad that it's not in the portrait but
i'll do we got all five
i mean my idea would have worked because
it would have
put fire to the portrait and then it
would have just
disintegrated and you could have walked
behind it but i mean this works too
maybe i should go and save
yeah i think i'm gonna go and save i'll
put this mask of
joy on and then save
before lady d finds me
how much blood and sweat do you think it
took to raise those daughters
i don't care an impossible debt
are you walking away
she doesn't care oops oops she just came
right back
um wait can i just quickly do this wait
which one is it add joy joy joy joy
okay i've expanded my services please
come take a look sure naturally
i've procured some new items for you mr
winters
can i give you anything see i can give
you
the crystal tour so
yeah yeah i'll give you that
dissatisfied
i believe this is a fair price
yeah i have no idea why i've got this
lipstick do i just give it to you
i guess i do did i just did i steal a
lady to mistress
this is the lipstick just to sell it
because i feel kind of rude
doing that now let's carry on
shall we sell um lady d's lipstick
i don't know
i think we should it's yeah because i
heard
i heard i haven't been cheating but i
heard that apparently if you
save some things and sell them together
you actually make more money
but i don't think her lipstick is part
of like
a larger collective of things that you
can sell
i think this i might be if we can't use
it
somewhere it says combinable so it seems
like it would be
this doesn't say combinable so you're
gonna sell the lipstick
uh and that's probably all i'm gonna
sell
see i've got sniper rifle ammo but i
don't have a sniper rifle
yet
oh yeah uh okay so max this out
that's great love that
i guess why not this simple modification
can be done in just a moment
please do take a look at my new stock
okay so i can hold more supplies sure
i'll take it
oh jesus i forgot you were here i was
too busy
dealing with technical difficulties bye
okay
so i put the mask of joy
i think she's lost me oh the entire
bloodline of
house dummy trask is done in by the
likes of you
uh yeah you're impressed
oh how dare i
haven't been doing this
how's the metres i need to go back up
there please
[Music]
she's going the way that i want to go
not fair
where's she gonna go when she reaches
okay she's going that way i want to go
the other way so this is good
whoa something shiny up there
did you not hear that ladies
dummy chest
because she's quite tired she says how
stomach dress is
done in by the likes of you
come here come this way
i want to get that thing that she
dropped on the floor
oh [ __ ] now she didn't fall for it
[Music]
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh my god
oh my god we lost her
thank god she didn't see what i did to
her portrait
oh she's cleverer than i thought she was
oh
i really want to get what i dropped on
the floor
i just want to get that thing that i
dropped on the floor i just want to know
what it is
oh crystal well that's nice
okay hmm
turn around oh you
oh i was trying to
kind of knife it i have to waste it
on you fine oh
it's magic
oh treasure map hello
okay there's something on this table too
i heard there was something called the
dagger of death's flowers
somewhere in this castle it's apparently
an antique from the middle ages
that's coated in a concoction of poisons
from across the continent
it's said to have been crafted to kill
demons and monsters
it sounds fascinating but no one knows
where it is
an antique coated ink in a concoction of
poisons surely
it could kill anything so we have to be
very careful with it
don't pick it up the wrong way round
um
let's check out this map i still just
really just want to craft some health
i don't like not having any health wait
somehow i had can fluid didn't realize i
picked that up to be honest
okay well that's good then
now we'll wait
uh
so kitchen's dungeon oh okay
treasure
did we not already find this i think we
found this
there's an heirloom worth of fortune in
the nobleman's casket
but there's a damn trick to it something
about lighting the way
we've already done this i swear we've
already this is when i was trying to use
my bloody head to swing
the thing to get it alight i'm pretty
yeah we've done that
we have definitely done that
here we go here we go
here we go
excuse me i think i just heard something
growl at me
did you guys see that
ah
now we know why we need to sniper rifle
it's not wasteless
two bullets
[Music]
is that one no that's just the goggle ah
the red herring
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh we know well i think i know where
that goes down to
thank you [ __ ] jesus
feel the wrath of my shotgun it's a good
study
oh god
shotgun's my favorite i love the shotgun
so i guess if i get them from as far
then i don't have to worry about
having to get them close up fair enough
uh can i change what's here
how do i do this again
shortcut down yeah
oh god where'd he come from
look at that
see you land somewhere don't you
[Music]
headshot
[Music]
idiot
oh what the hell are you doing
you can't move through walls
you're not a ghost yet
we found a bug ladies and gentlemen
oh that means i couldn't pick up
anything that it dropped
oh wow
right question is this one or is this a
gargoyle
oh i hate these red herrings i don't
know
i feel like it is one it kind of looks
like one but it's not moving at all
[Music]
[Music]
are you alive yes you are i [ __ ] knew
it
nope nope nope nope not again you are
not going underneath the banister
come here come here
[ __ ] it where are they where you are
well at least you did very creatively
[Applause]
they definitely are friendly maria i'm
shooting
another one where
i thought i'd killed them all now
i don't like these things
hello
i can hear it like like it's up here
somewhere
oh it's right in my ear i don't like it
can you guys hear it tell me you can
hear it
thank you very much
thank you very much
[Music]
[Music]
ugh
[Music]
why why
okay if you still hear some but
no i don't want to say it it's going to
say something but
it would just drink jesus or me
primarily
camp fluid yeah
oh hell yeah
good looks like i got most of them with
my
gun so we good
our rifle did its job and now we just go
back down again
why did i come here then
[Music]
no surely there's gotta be something
that i
missed
oh we're going into terror of rage
hell yeah take me there take me there
[Music]
sorry
darndest
when you die
okay i should be able to get out with
these
they're all in the same pose
which is a little bit sad it'd be cool
to see them in different poses
because the joy mask did not make any
sense
this one being rage yeah that makes
sense
i could even weirdly see this as
pleasure you know
but yeah
[Music]
okay uh
his money will be over here
i think he died yes
we've got the can through weird oh can i
go
oh that's nice of the game i think they
put this here with the idea in mind that
you might kill it
and it might fall down here maybe i mean
maybe i'm giving it too much credit but
that's nice of them to think about us
if they didn't
maybe i should craft some
shotgun or oh or another
first aid now i'm going to get shotgun i
can do professor
as well
oh this is the last mask hell yeah
uh
hello hello nearly missed you there
didn't i
she's always hanging out by these stairs
see what did i tell ya
uh lady lady
hello
she just disappeared what the hell
no the entire bloodline of
house domitrask is done in by the likes
of
you yep
you've said that to me a few times now
are you forgetful do you have a
short-term memory
and you are going through traumas so i
get it
oh gosh i want to take off a hand i've
expanded my services
please come take a look
okay oh good i was just thinking of ways
to pass the time
please do take a look at my new stock
well now that would be worth it
um is the only thing i can sell oh yeah
there is
i got this crystal fragment
securing goods is more important than
anything
anything
so it's only got one
the power's quite good not already it
seems like you're one hit kill
for the bat things anyway
so let's do capacity
what ah it's fine all finished
and let's
see anything else
till next we meet
perfect we got all we got all the math
right let's
see what's going to happen [ __ ]
the door's open
bye lady bye lady
noise
how are we guaranteeing now
uh
i feel like something's gonna happen
once i open that coffin
i don't know where you guys maybe it's
just you know
jagman intuition
there's literally nothing to collect in
here either
not that i can see anyway
okay let's do this thing
ruined everything
that's amazing
i will defend
[Music]
oh god we are finished
i hope it goes away
[Applause]
uh
okay
i don't even need anything
[Applause]
[Applause]
where's my shotgun
much
just give up
i'll kill you i'll kill you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
we'll save
is
um
hello
[Applause]
don't be shy show me your terror
every last one
[Applause]
yes
[Applause]
what the hell
okay that was freaking it says that i
really did not see that coming
i thought we had a long way to go until
i had to go one-on-one with
dimitri
now i am lady dimitrisk
but uh unfortunately i can't turn into
that really cool like monster thing with
wings
because uh that was crazy
okay how are we doing how are we feeling
we're feeling great
we're on green health we're good we're
good
um we have no shotgun ammo but
[Music]
it's fine
i i actually did not did not see that
coming
at all
i should have seen it coming we just
fought winged like creatures
and vampires turned into bats so
looks like i'm getting out of this place
good
love a good dirty flask um is there
nothing she can
like drop or something because it oh
look at these teeth
it'd be nice to get anything
apart from a dirty flask it would be
nice to get
something anything out here
let's have a look at our dirty flask
can i open it
it's got a picture of like a fetus on it
stabilizing compounds procedure is
untested
and early something destroyed too
quickly to collect
definitive okay i'm not too sure what
this is
but i'm sure we'll find out
a glass container with the flower and
swords crest it's too dirty to see
inside
but it looks kind of like a fence
she said it was too late for us to get
rose but
i'm inclined not to believe her
oh it's a type friday looks like we got
ourselves a save room
okay i'll take that scrap
nothing in here
i finished that item that was requested
please deliver it to the house with the
red chimney
go through the caves to the ruins then
down into the village
i will save i'm just going to have a
little look around first
powder nice
i don't know what i need here to
to do these
still a mystery to me i can't believe
we've killed lady dimitrisk it's so
weird i thought she would be there
throughout most of the game but i guess
not
maybe i'm further in than i realized i
don't know
it's very strange
okay then on that note
i'm gonna say goodbye
[Music]
i will see you guys next thursday 8 30
pm
uh look out for videos and all that jazz
and thank you so much for being so
patient with me
through this time of annoying burnout
and tiredness
and whatever it means a lot i
i appreciate you guys always being so
understanding
on this channel we may not be the
quickest to like complete games or
whatever
but we put mental health first and i
think that's really important
i hope you have a lovely day or evening
and yeah
i'll see you next time